hello I'm in the Seljuk Critic guy
remember so you don't have to well I'm
back in my commercial garb
then let me we're talking about
commercials but not just any commercial
correct repairs all independent and oh
you thought mass marketing was insane
try mass marketing around Christmas time
many of these commercials are so popular
they repeat them every year how crazy is
that an ad campaign you don't even have
to change because people love the
nostalgia so much well I love nostalgia
too and that's why we're going to count
down the top well best Christmas
commercials ever top white hats well
well I'll tell you in saw most of us are
familiar with the classic anime is short
the Snowman it was surreal whimsical and
beautifully animated well a UK drink
cold iron brew did their own take on the
classic short and in this one it isn't
just magic that brings them to life but
the opening of the refreshing drink it
goes just like the original even down to
the singing boys boys
that is until the snowman wants a drink
of its brew
no man gets more and more pissed off
until he decides he's just done with a
little snot
[Music]
not only is the commercial funny but the
way it replicates the original short
from the animation to the music it's
definitely a loving parenting one that
brings laugh as well as the nostalgic
feelings of why we love the original
unlike some other Christmas parody
commercial demographic you'll run the
bill up kid Marlys not every commercial
on this list has to be good it just has
to stand out as something we relate to
the holiday
well this enjoyably awkward commercial
certainly stands out and people are
making a tradition of watching it every
year now it's just a guy turning home
and his loved one making him some coffee
after being away in West Africa long way
from West Africa brought you something
from far away really she waited up all
night for him he playfully pretends he
got the wrong house he gets her a gift
and she lovingly puts the bow on him and
says here my presentation they're
brother and sister yep this is incest in
the what the figgy pudding degree now
don't get me wrong they don't surprise
you with it at the end in fact they make
it very clear in the opening I dare even
say uncomfortably clear I must have the
wrong house sister who just says that
who announces their connection to
someone when they opened the door after
confused but even knowing that going in
and yes you can take that in a different
way their body language the way they
talk and just the all-around mood
indicates that they're a couple it's
beyond creepy don't believe me just
watch it with this music what are you
doing here my present this year
[Music]
this commercial has become so infamously
eue
that parodies are popping up all over
the place people love to mock how
incestuously bizarre it is mothers and
sisters don't look at each other like
that
okay whether you find it charming or
it's sure to get reaction every
Christmas tasted nuts and honey mrs.
burger at the knees are of course hates
Christmas and says humbug can acquire
outside but it's the great taste of
honey and nuts that snaps and instantly
back into the Christmas mood
[Music]
oh wow that all those girls are really
kicking themselves that they wasted an
entire night on this guy we didn't need
any visions or tombstones we just needed
the commanding military of General Mills
who is that easy I love that the B
brings up honey nut cheerios and
Christmas together
like it's some sort of tradition
everybody knows about Nigeria listen to
me come on honey nut cheerios and
Christmas they go hand in hand like KFC
and Christmas in Japan besides we all
know the real serial to bring out
Christmas and you with Christmas crunch
if you'll find crack I told ya it'll
make the roof of your mouth bleed for a
week and we love it it's do a really
great ad lo with great atmosphere and
cold colors
it'll charm the Dickinson to you
[Music]
lilius oh yeah I can't forget these
scary sons of bitches I don't know how
many people remember this ad but while
most kids were dreaming visions of
sugarplums we had these little
healthpons dancing around in our not
only were these things but freakiest sin
but their jingle was so catchy that many
people reported ear bleeding's with the
blood spelling out the name nestling so
even our bodily fluids knew how to spell
it in with that catfish seriousness
really was very big thinking these
things only have teeth on their bottom
jaws they look like marshmallows that
can somehow bite into your soul and
don't look directly into those eyes Mike
Myers nap has more humanity to it and
just when you think it couldn't get any
scarier they fill the whole screen with
them thank you very much it alone
it's disturbing nightmare inducing and
all-around unforgettable sleep well
tonight dreaming of your Christmas
Lipper is coming to life and trying to
eat you a new holiday wrapping from
Nestle Nestle Mary Lou
remember I talked about this one before
but by god it deserves to be talked
about again it's crazy how much they
showed this commercial it was everywhere
around Christmastime this is Barney and
once again trying to get Fred's Fruity
Pebbles let's stand up beaten to it as
it happens but Santa says it's good to
share and the spread finally give them a
bowl tis the season to be sharing Fred
Happy Holidays pal or food the kershel
of course raises so many questions how
can they celebrate Christmas if Jesus
isn't born yet
what's the origins of caveman Santa
Claus how the hell is Dino a singer but
my biggest question I never noticed
before it's white bread giving Santa an
Apple that in no way makes sense first
off it's cookies and milk but ok let's
say he switched it out and made it for B
pebbles what the hell is an Apple gonna
add to anything you're giving him that
with grounded Froot Loops it's the idea
that there's so little actual fruit in
it that giving him an Apple will somehow
make up for it I don't know but what I
do know is the commercials been played
so many times it has our childhood by
the balls for a bowl using bold right
because hell's are pretty pebbles being
our but you know don't answer that
Internet
I bet stop your pebbles regardless it's
still a lot of Rudi and cocoa pebbles
the real part of a nutritious breakfast
[Music]
remember that that has had a lot of
great Christmas as one with the girl
talking about running away to McDonald
and another with a star that needs
people packing this guy he's going to
Santa Claus the movie tie-in that must
have paid off but the one people seem to
enjoy the most is the skating one a
bunch of kids go to the nicest ice ring
set they've ever seen where they see a
creepy ass clown skating he takes them
for a spin but one kid is having trouble
keeping up the kid has left out rattle
seems to take off the fear makes fun of
him but then Ronald comes back picks and
mop and gives him a magical moment
because the music indicates it's a
magical moment
I think it has the biggest impact
because there's no talking in it it's
nothing but music visual that
bored-looking dear seriously what's the
story because of that man makes it a bit
more universal anyone can watch it
immediately know what's going on and
feel the warm special feeling when a
stranger in clown makeup picked you up
and doesn't let you go the commercial
makes it sound a lot nicer than I do
it's a good ad that continues to bring a
smile to a lot of people speak
[Music]
number six another and I've talked about
before but certainly deserve a spot on
the list in many respects it's not even
really a Christmas man Christmas is
never mentioned but the idea of a
snowman coming in from the cold again
warmed up by soup how can this not lead
to a lot of warm fuzzies that connect
you with the holiday I think what makes
it work is the contrast it's not just
cold it's sideways snow cold and the
inside isn't just warm it's someone
throwing a Norman Rockwell painting on
the fireplace warm the two extremes
brought together equal the perfect mix
that leaves an impression on your
nostalgia Plus that 10 impressive puppet
I mean they did a really good job on
that thing the only question I ever had
was how could he actually eat the soup
it always cut away before we could see
it do the rocks open up do they form an
open mouth where does the soup go when
he needs to take up to again I know that
don't answer that
a great ad to make you feel nice and
cozy every time
[Music]
this one just came out this year and
already people can't stop talking about
it it's one of the oddest Christmas
commercial to ever come out and that's
saying something we see a man in the
mountains recording something on his
iPhone
he seems happy hanging pictures of
in-joke on his wall when he suddenly
gets up and goes down to the village in
a bizarre twist
it's the Frankenstein monster got us but
that's not where it stopped he goes in
front of the town tree and puts two
Christmas lights in his bolts yeah
clever but it doesn't stop there
he starts singing there's no place like
home for the holidays whoa look whoa um
um but then one of his life goes out and
everyone looks pissed
stupid Frankenstein monster I'm so not
impressed by anything but then a girl
goes up fixes his light she starts
singing and then everyone starts singing
what the hell was that
this was so strange so random so
bizarrely mixing whatever emotions we
can't describe in a pot of I don't know
it's so out there that in a strange way
you have to admire it it is so strange
but it clearly has a good heart too I
think that kind of motion does shine
through and everyone else seems to think
so too
though Ray has millions of hits on
YouTube just one day after it premiered
and is still going strong it can't be
explained it just has to be seen so the
next time Raymond's brother tries to
steal the spotlight and people find it
uncomfortable just send a little kid in
to sing with him and subtly everyone
will find it cool Christmas we're trying
so hard to kind of make it Halloween
[Music]
the coolest scent a trademark of
Christmas even down to Santa's red and
white outfit so it's no wonder that to
continuing commercials would tie the
spot here
one is the Santa packs it's just a dark
cold night when subtly the Santa packs
jingle is heard people who put all their
love of the holidays and sugar liquid
syrup rejoice as the Santa truck to
light up the night one boy said because
I don't know other coke is beamed into
his hands by creepy anime and Santa and
all is right with the world the other
one is the coca-cola polar bears it's
light because the first ant doesn't even
make a whole lot of sense it shows a
bunch of bears who watch the Northern
Lights drink a coke and that's it
[Music]
inspired but the imagery was just so
relaxing and so for lack of a better
word cool they had to keep bringing them
back every year each has a story that
usually went nowhere but just looks so
damn awesome going nowhere they were
visual spectacles then and they're still
visual spectacles now so that's why
today both Santa and the polar bears are
seen on the coca-cola box both have nice
winter colors that make you feel the
cold but also appreciate it at the same
time seeing how these ads are still
going today coke definitely means it
when they say always
[Music]
it's not out a nostalgic obligation it's
perhaps out of pure Dawber and
dedication that this one makes the list
the Hershey Kisses ringing wish you a
Merry Christmas it's Hershey's
longest-running
ass debuting in 1989 and still going
strong today to make the story behind it
even more interesting the brand manager
John Donne was tasked with making
several whimsical Hershey commercials
but was told not to do a Christmas one
what do you like this idea so much and
knew it would be a hit that he did it
anyway and we're still thankful in
hindsight it's not much it's
disgustingly simple but maybe that's why
it laughs it is simple anyone can see it
giggle we feel good afterwards it's not
trying to be too big or too sentimental
just a little happy moment not unlike a
little Hershey kiss chocolate it makes
perfect sense to say anymore we ruin its
simplicity which honestly speaks for
itself so we'll just leave it as it is
[Applause]
[Music]
number two cow another one that makes
the rounds every Christmas and another
one that seems so disgustingly simple be
M&Ms are setting up red and green M&Ms
for Santa which seems cannibalistic the
more I think about it when says it
appears and they both pass out to exist
the M&Ms were always popular commercials
but they hit a big when they were given
individual personalities
suddenly the M&Ms were as popular as
Disney or Warner Brothers cartoons we
knew who they were and loved them but we
look forward every year to seeing them
interact with Santa the same way this is
a reminder how far marketing can come
turning hardshell chocolates into
classic cartoon characters we never get
tired of watching them and we look
forward to seeing this one several
Christmases more what can you say but
you don't mess with a classic oh Santa
now before we get to number one here are
a few runners-up the Budweiser worth
some connected to Christmas so why not
edica a grandpa tries dying just to get
the family together that's pretty ballsy
but not as baldie as Kmart's jingle bell
just for the shock that they got away
with this at all
Santa Anna norelco razor an oldie but a
goodie Amazon Prime's commercial where a
real priest and a mangy 40 showing unity
and religions and staples creating an
insane snowman robot pretty hard not to
get a lab here but all right let's get
to number one and the number one
Christmas commercial and oh yeah you
better believe I'm doing this dia
thing's Barry has done a lot of
emotional commercials in the past the
majority of them get millions of hits on
YouTube but that's the one that has to
be the most powerful has to be the 2014
ad because it's based on an unbelievable
true story in 1914 on Christmas during
World War one battling sides decided to
put aside their differences stop killing
each other and go out in a sign of peace
for one day they suddenly went from
trying to kill one another to treating
each other like brothers they shared
stories treats presents anything they
had to make the ad even more powerful it
was released exactly 100 years after the
event took place they actually tried so
hard to get this right that they teamed
up with the Royal British Legion to get
the details down there's even a making
of the commercial on YouTube to show how
hard they tried to get it the chocolate
bar as well was sold in stores and the
profits all went to the Royal British
Allegiant to benefit their Armed Forces
and their families this adds so easily
could have come across as manipulative
or even corny but they did everything in
their power to make sure the proud
message of that night wasn't lost
it's a powerful commercial that
represents a powerful point in history
now their effort doesn't go unrecognized
and when you watch it all you can think
is yes
that's what Christmas is all about I'm
the Nostalgia Critic let's remember
together
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing Direct
Relief Direct Relief is a medical aid
organization active in all 50 states and
in 70 countries with the mission to
improve the health and lives of people
affected by poverty or emergency
situation this is among the largest
medical suppliers to West Africa in
response to the Ebola epidemic the
Philippines following typhoon Haiyan and
Haiti after the 2010 earthquake Direct
Relief earns a 100 percent fundraising
efficiency rating from Fort top Charity
Navigator Liz of top 10 charities
everyone heard of and is named by vast
company among the world's most
innovative companies and nonprofits this
is a wonderful organization that does so
much good and hard work if you go to
their YouTube channel or their site you
can see all the great stuff they can do
and how you can help them in that great
work so please definitely take a look
open your heart and see what you can do
to help these great people
you